hi I'm sure I ate a lot of sugar honey
here story on a tiny story it's a really
cool tough lady story called kungfu mom
there once was this girl was around
probably about 100 years ago do super
tough even though she was lady she even
smoked a cigarette one whenever someone
make her mad who usually kick him in the
face the only thing she loved more than
kicking butts with baseball cards did my
mom said people collected them back then
one day she was organizing the carts by
coolest-looking guy when I let her slide
under doorway she was like what the heck
so she open it up and read it and it
said hey there I'm a bad guy I stole
your favorite baseball card it's the
Rolly fingers with Rickey cards she
loved Riley fingers peace he had a
really cool toy really moustache letter
said that the bad guy was gonna bend the
card in half and rough off the corner so
it wouldn't be in mint condition anymore
said that the bad guy was at Coney
Island we went on vacation so she
grabbed her roller skates - started
rolling to Coney Island
she was jumping over curbs my five cool
people punching out me people sometimes
she dances because there were some cool
rollerskating music play then she saw a
bus and got up but said not roller skate
so she gave him to some old grandma with
an eyepatch and got on the bus but after
a few stops she realized she had sagging
jelly and she was so mad she jumped off
and ran for a walk - so fast she could
run the mile in about six minutes flat
there's a couple of ninjas popped out
and she knew they were bad so she'd kick
one of them peanuts then give them bad
movie
and she stole his nunchucks like another
ninja and he got a bloody nose and
passed out then she stole that English
grenade the heck out of the other ninja
like quickly painting it to look like an
act and giving it to him as a gift he
smiles and took a bite like an idiot and
I blew chunks of his body everywhere
then she saw a guy riding a bike she
kicked him up north at Ohio high-fiving
more cool people punching out more idiot
then she saw a taxicab
so she hopped in and load that for a
while it sunk like armpits in it so she
got out from ansible and when she was
crossing the bridge some guy called her
a cuss word
so she tore his nipples off and threw
him in the bike basket thing and after a
few blocks the blanket rip born so she
got up and ran to the subway and the
whole time she's kept thinking about
Riley fingers and swirly mustache then
she looked around and everyone at
toys-r-us fashion that was the last
straw she needed to get that car finally
got to Coney Island and ran through the
carnival area and played a quick round
of skee-ball it is fun okay and that the
wizard reader for and said go kick your
butt right now baby so she went to the
bad guy headquarter stick to crap out of
the door and that's when she got a ride
fingers car then she saw the bad guy
until they both ran for the car she got
to it first and just threw her right at
him like a ninja star
and he said aw crap then she took her
fingers and put her laugh is robbing the
trans butthole - so excited actually
picked up an electric guitar while he
played a lab so without making any
mistakes my mom she was playing my
fingers himself walked in and fell in
love with the light away so he went in
the back room and got naked and all the
Bucks get our thing and that made a baby
and he was in sugar boy and he was
awesome
I wish my dad with my fingers
[Music]
you